why does a book fail to become a movie
if somebody wants to adapt a book and
they think they buy the right whatever
it is and just somehow doesn't translate
it doesn't work out well there are
hundreds of reasons why that can happen
but but they come back in in categories
that you get used to
every book that's submitted to Hollywood
is what's called covered and in my
various webinars I talk about coverage
and coverage is a industry term for a
story report where a reader in the story
Department of a agency or of a
production company or a studio or in any
part of the business where stories go to
be covered and they're covered because
the executives who make the decisions
can't possibly read all the stories that
come in too many things are submitted
too many stories are submitted and in
the coverage it covers every single part
of the story from a one-line pitch of
the story to the genre of the story the
category the length of the story the
quality of the writing the dialogue the
characters sporting characters you know
main characters supporting characters
plot etc so you get a full report in
four or five pages that analyzes the
story and then it ends with
recommendation pass consider with
development you know or accept with
development or just accept and and
accepts are extremely rare I mean
probably one to two percent or in that
category and the reason that most books
are turned down I've already mentioned
some of them but has to do with not
clear who the protagonist is not strong
enough antagonists too many characters
if you can't figure out what's important
what's not important too much repetition
the dialogue the characters don't sound
different from each other they all sound
the same and we all know from literary
you know literature
graduate school that one of the common
questions that you asked as you're just
given lines of dialogue from plays and
asked to identify the character by one
line of dialogue because the great
playwrights make their dialogue
characteristic to each character and
lady even get that Macbeth would not be
sounding like Juliet you know there
there always be clear who's talking and
and that's another reason for a frequent
turndowns
the audience isn't big enough you know a
story about Latvian Americans take in a
small neighborhood in Detroit you know
may get made as an indie movie if you
know somebody like Meryl Streep wants to
be in it because she's Latvian you know
but other than that the chances are that
Fox is not going to develop it because
they're looking at audience appeal you
know they're looking at demographics so
any of those reasons and all of those
reasons are are reasons why a book gets
turned down sometimes the book is to
internal and screenwriters struggle with
it but they can't figure out how to
externalize the constant thinking and
philosophizing of a character there are
examples of books that have done that
well like the world according to GARP
you know is an example but they're
usually internal stories are very hard
to turn into films and and what happens
is halfway through the attempt to do
that you realize you're inventing all
the dialogue and then how much that and
therefore how true is this movie to the
book at all you know is it even the same
book because if the book did everything
internally and you're inventing all the
dialogue you know what I mean it's so
there are a lot of reasons but they all
have to do with with drama drama is
about scenes and the scene is which is
is a place and time in which there is
conflict two forces come together in
conflict and the conflict is resolved
and that scene is the unit of drama
and if the scenes in a book are not
clear enough scenes are very
distinguished in books and Vonnegut for
example his scenes can be two sentences
long in you know in Faulkner his scenes
can be 20 pages long and but but still
he'll be clear scenes my favorite
example of I think is a shortest story
in American literature is goes like this
have you lived next door to a man who's
trying to plate to learning to play the
viola that's what she asked the police
when she handed them the empty revolver
it's a it's a short story by a Richard
Brautigan and but there's a whole scene
write a whole story a whole scene told
in a couple of lines and just as the
tour de force to show that you don't
need a lot of words to make a scene we
get it right away and and that's drama
is a scene like that and there are two
kinds two components of drama as I
talked about in my various books I mean
one of them is action she hands them the
empty revolver and the other is dialogue
have you tried living next door to a
person learning to play the viola you
know that those are the two components
of action and drama dialogue and action
and dialogue like good morning how you
doing today is not dramatic and yet many
novels are filled with it with that kind
of dialogue so the great novelists that
have been made into great movies have
vital dialogue that is really action
dialogue like sublime from Hemingway
that I love to quote in creative writing
classes these two people sitting near a
train station and at one point she says
to him would you please please please
please please please stop talking and
that's a great example of a piece of
dialogue that is pure action you know
that there's no hope for their
relationship after she says that and and
and it goes on to say the man did not
say anything for a while
then he asked would you like a beer and
we know you know it's all over between
them but there's an example of how great
dialog is you know like from Chinatown
you my mother my sister my mother my
sister my mother my sister remember that
he said tell the truth and she keeps
saying the same thing over and over
again until he finally realizes that
she's telling the truth
and that's when you have you know that
the writer knows what he's doing and
that's right it's why screenplay writing
is so much more difficult than novelist
because there are the harshest rules in
writing screenplays and in the harsh
rule really is only one harsh rule every
single word in the screenplays connected
to every other word and in a novel
that's just not true I mean you can't
you know the 600 page novel that just
can't be true and it isn't true but it
is true in the screenplay because if you
say a word and the audience you know
leaves the theater and they loved it
otherwise you know at the bar they're
gonna say but why did he say that one
thing to him like it made no sense you
know take care of yourself why do you
say that at the end of that scene and
they won't let go of that until they
figure it out and if they can't figure
it out thinking oh there's something
wrong with that story you know because
it's all you know like you can't focus a
camera on a red hat in a movie without
making that payoff later and and that's
just not true of novels for one thing
novels kind of float in in the air of
the reader you know as you read the book
you paint pictures in your head and
movies are much more demanding than that
because they have to make decisions what
does she look like and you you have to
cast her with the right color here and
you know one of the most famous lines in
history is from the Iliad when everyone
knows Helen of Troy is supposed to be
the most beautiful woman who ever lived
right but Homer is not going to deal
with that because that's just impossible
so what happens is it says when she
appeared he says the olders detroy were
standing on the walls of Troy
chattering like locusts with each other
until Helen tell gel a hush fell among
them as Helen appeared and one of them
says terrible indeed is her likeness to
that of an immortal goddess and that is
the entire description of Helen of Troy
which you know can't be beat because it
leaves it completely to your imagination
what'd she look like and he wasn't about
to say she was no five foot two red hair
blue eyes etc which immediately will
kill her beauty in some people's minds
and so it's that's why drama is so much
more challenging
it's the ultimate expression of
storytelling and it's why movies are you
know hugely powerful instruments around
the world
you